sie erklärte
präsident herunter
und es kann
wenn frau bundespräsidentin meine damen
und herren abgeordnete es ist mir ehre
und freude vor diesem hohen haus zu
sprechen
vor dem parlament meines deutschen
vaterlandes das als demokratisch
gewählte volksvertretung hier
zusammenkommt um zum wohl der
bundesrepublik deutschland zu arbeiten
dem herrn bundestagspräsident möchte ich
für seine einladung zu dieser rede
ebenso danken wir für die vereinbarung
freundlichen worte der begrüßung und
wertschätzung mit denen er mich
empfangen hat in dieser stunde wende ich
mich an sie verehrte damen und herren
gewiss auch als landsmann der sich
lebenslang seiner herkunft verbunden
weiß und die geschicke der deutschen
heimat mit anteilnahme verfolgt aber die
einladung zu dieser rede gilt mir als
papst als bischof von rom der die
oberste verantwortung für die
katholische christenheit trägt
sie anerkennen damit die rolle die dem
heiligen stuhl als partner innerhalb der
völker und staatengemeinschaft zukommt
von dieser meiner internationalen
verantwortung möchte ich ihnen einige
gedanken über die grundlagen des
freiheitlichen rechtsstaates vorlegen
lassen sie mich meine überlegungen über
die grundlagen des rechts mit einer
kleinen geschichte aus der heiligen
schrift beginnen
im ersten buch der könige wird erzählt
dass gott dem jungen könig salomon bei
seiner thronbesteigung eine bitte
freistellte
was wenn sich der junge herrscher in
diesem augenblick erbitten erfolg
reichtum langes leben vernichtung der
feinde nicht um diese dinge bittet er
bittet verleih deinem knecht ein
hörendes herz
damit er dem volk zu regieren und das
gute vom bösen zu unterscheiden versteht
die bibel bildungs mit dieser erzählung
sagen worauf es für einen politiker
letztlich ankommen muss sein letzter
maßstab und der grund für seine arbeit
als politiker darf nicht der erfolg und
schon gar nicht materieller gewinn sein
die politik muss mühen um gerechtigkeit
sein und so die grundvoraussetzung für
friede schaffen
natürlich wird ein politiker den erfolg
suchen ohne den er überhaupt nicht die
möglichkeit politischer gestaltung hätte
aber der erfolg ist dem maßstab der
gerechtigkeit dem willen zum recht und
dem verstehen für das recht
untergeordnet
erfolg kann auch verführung sein und
kann so den weg auftun für die
verfälschung des rechts für die
zerstörung der gerechtigkeit
nimm das recht weg was ist dann ein
staat noch anderes als eine große
räuberbande hat der heilige augustinus
einmal gesagt wir deutsche wissen es aus
eigener erfahrung dass diese worte nicht
ein leeres schreckgespenst sind
wir haben erlebt dass macht von recht
getrennt wurde
das macht gegen recht stand das recht
zertreten hat und dass der staat zum
instrument der rechts zerstörung wurde
seiner sehr gut organisierten
räuberbande die die ganze welt bedrohen
und an den rand des abgrunds treiben
konnte dem recht zu dienen und der
herrschaft des unrechts zu wehren ist
und bleibt die grundlegende aufgabe des
politikers in einer historischen stunde
in der dem menschen macht zugefallen ist
die bisher nicht vorstellbar war wird
diese aufgabe besonders
der mensch kann die welt zerstören
er kann sich selbst manipulieren er kann
sozusagen menschen machen und menschen
vom menschsein ausschließen
wie erkennen wir was recht ist wir
können wir zwischen gut und böse
zwischen wahrem recht und schein recht
unterscheiden
diese harmonische bitte bleibt
entscheidende frage wo der der politiker
und die politik auch heute stehen in
einem großteil der rechtlich zu
regelnden materien kann die mehrheit ein
genügendes kriterium sein
aber dass in den grundfragen des rechts
in denen es um die würde des menschen
und der menschheit geht das
mehrheitsprinzip nicht ausreicht ist
offenkundig jeder verantwortliche muss
sich bei der rechts bildung die
kriterien seiner orientierung suchen
im dritten jahrhundert hat der große
theologe originals den widerstand der
christen gegen bestimmte geltende
rechtsordnungen so begründet wenn jemand
sich bei den skythen befände die
gottlose gesetze haben und gezwungen
wäre bei ihnen zu leben dann würde er
wohl sehr vernünftig handeln wenn im
namen des gesetzes der wahrheit dass bei
den skript ja gesetzwidrigkeit ist
zusammen mit gleichgesinnten auch
entgegen der bei jenen bestehen ordnung
vereinigungen bilden würde von dieser
überzeugung her haben die
widerstandskämpfer gegen das naziregime
und gegen andere totalitäre regime
gehandelt und so dem recht und der
menschheit als ganzer einen dienst
erwiesen
für diese menschen war es unbestreitbar
evident dass geltendes recht in
wirklichkeit unrecht war aber bei den
entscheidungen eines demokratischen
politikers ist die frage
was nun dem gesetz der wahrheit
entspreche was wahrheit was wahnhaft
recht und gesetz werden können nicht
ebenso evident was in bezug auf die
grundlegenden anthropologischen fragen
das rechte ist und geltendes recht
werden kann liegt heute keineswegs
einfach zu tage
die frage wie man das wahrhaft rechte
erkennen und so der gerechtigkeit in der
gesetzgebung dienen kann war nie einfach
zu beantworten
es ist heute in der fülle unseres
wissens und unseres könnens noch sehr
viel schwieriger geworden
wie erkennt man was recht ist
in der geschichte sind rechtsordnungen
fast durchgehend religiös begründet
worden
vom blick auf die gottheit hier wird
entschieden was unter menschen rechtens
ist
im gegensatz zu anderen großen
religionen hat das christentum dem staat
und der gesellschaft nie eine
offenbarung recht nie eine rechtsordnung
aus offenbarung vorgegeben
es hat stattdessen auf natur und
vernunft als die wahren rechtsquellen
verwiesen auf den zusammenklang von
objektiver und subjektiver vernunft der
freilich dass gegründete seien beide
sphären in der schöpferischen vernunft
gottes voraussetzt
die christlichen theologen haben sich
damit einer philosophischen und
juristischen bewegung angeschlossen die
sich seit dem zweiten jahrhundert vor
christus gebildet hatte in der ersten
hälfte des zweiten vorchristlichen
jahrhunderts kam es zu einer begegnung
zwischen dem von stoischen philosophen
entwickelten sozialen
recht und verantwortlichen lehrern des
römischen rechts in dieser berührung ist
die abendländische rechtskultur geboren
worden die für die rechtskultur der
menschheit von entscheidender bedeutung
war und ist von dieser vorchristlichen
verbindung von recht und philosophie
geht der weg über das christliche
mittelalter in die rechts entfaltung der
aufklärungszeit bis hin zur erklärung
der menschenrechte und bis uns im
deutschen grundgesetz mit dem sich unser
volk 1949 zu den unverletzlichen und
unveräußerlichen menschenrechten als
grundlage jeder menschlichen
gemeinschaft des friedens und der
gerechtigkeit in der welt bekannt hat
für die entwicklung des rechts und für
die entwicklung der humanität war es
entscheidend dass sich die christlichen
theologen gegen das von götter glauben
geforderte religiöse recht auf die seite
der philosophie gesteht vernunft und
natur in ihrem zueinander als die für
alle gültige rechts quelle anerkannt
haben
diesen entscheid hatte schon paulus im
brief an die römer vollzogen wenn er
sagt wenn halten die das gesetz die
tories nicht haben von natur aus das tun
was im gesetz gefordert ist
so sind sie sich selbst gesetzt sie
zeigen damit dass ihnen die forderung
des gesetzes ins herz geschrieben ist er
gewissen legt zeugnis davon ab hier
scheinen die beiden grundbegriffe natur
und gewissen wobei gewissen nichts
anderes ist als das hörende herz
salomons als die der sprache des seins
geöffnete vernunft wenn damit bis in die
zeit der aufklärung der
menschenrechtserklärung nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg und in der gestaltung unseres
grundgesetz
die frage nach den grundlagen der
gesetzgebung geklärt schien es hört sich
im letzten halben jahrhundert eine
dramatische veränderung der situation
zugetragen
der gedanke dass natürliches gilt heute
als eine katholische sonder lehre über
die außerhalb des katholischen raums zu
diskutieren nicht lohnen würde so dass
man sich schon beinahe schämt das wort
überhaupt zu erwähnen
ich möchte kurz andeuten wieso diese
situation entstanden ist
grundlegend ist zunächst die these dass
zwischen sein und sollen ein
unüberbrückbarer graben bestehen aus
sein könne kein sollen folgen
weil es sich dann zwei völlig
verschiedene bereiche handel
der grund dafür ist dass inzwischen fast
allgemein angenommene positivistische
verständnis von natur
wenn man die natur mit den worten von
hans kelsen als ein aggregat von als
ursache und wirkung miteinander
verbunden als seins tatsachen ansieht
dann kann es in der tat keine irgendwie
geartete ethische weisung hervorgehen
ein positivistischer naturbegriff der
die natur rein funktional versteht so
wie die naturwissenschaft sie erkennt
kann keine brücke zu ethos und recht
herstellen sondern wiederum nur
funktionale antworten hervorrufen
das gleiche gilt aber auch für die
vernunft in einem positivistischen
weithin als allein wissenschaftlich
angesehenen verständnis was nicht
verifizierbar oder falsifiziert ist
gehört er noch nicht in den bereich der
vernunft im strengen sinn
deshalb müssen ethos und religion dem
raum des subjektiven zugewiesen werden
und fallen aus dem bereich der vernunft
im strengen sinn des wortes heraus wo
die alleinige herrschaft der
positivistischen vernunft
und das ist in unserem öffentlichen
bewusstsein weithin der fall da sind die
klassischen erkenntnisquellen für ethos
und recht außer kraft gesetzt
dies ist eine dramatische situation die
alle angeht und über die eine
öffentliche diskussion notwendig ist zu
der dringend einzuladen eine wesentliche
absicht dieser rede bildet das
positivistische konzept von natur und
vernunft die positivistische weltsicht
als ganze ist ein großartiger teil
menschlichen erkennens und menschlichen
könnens auf die wir keinesfalls
verzichten dürfen
aber es ist nicht selbst als ganzes eine
dem menschsein in seiner weite
entsprechende und genügende kultur und
die positivistische vernunft sich allein
als die genügende kultur ansieht und
alle anderen kulturellen realitäten in
den status der subkultur verbannt da
verkleinert sie den menschen ja sie
bedroht seine menschlichkeit
ich sage das gerade im hinblick auf
europa in dem weite kreise versuchen nur
den positivismus als gemeinsame kultur
und als gemeinsame grundlage für die
rechts bildung anzuerkennen alle übrigen
einsichten und werte unserer kultur in
den status einer subkultur verwiesen und
damit europa gegenüber den anderen
kulturen der welt in einen status der
kulturlosigkeit gerückt und zugleich
extremistische und radikale strömungen
herausgefordert werden
die sich exklusiv gebende
positivistische vernunft die über das
funktionieren hinaus nichts wahrnehmen
kann gleicht den betonbauten ohne
fenster in denen in denen wir uns klima
und licht selber geben beides nicht mehr
aus der weiten welt gottes beziehen
und dabei können wir uns doch nicht
verbergen dass wir in dieser selbst
gemachten welt im stillen doch aus den
vorräten gottes schöpfen die wir zu
unseren produkten umgestalten
die fenster müssen wieder aufgerissen
werden wir müssen wieder die weite der
welt den himmel und die erde sehen und
all dies recht zu gebrauchen lernen
aber wie geht das wie viel wenn die
weite ins ganze
wie kann die vernunft wieder ihre größe
finden ohne ins irrationale abzugleiten
wie kann die natur wieder in ihrer
wahren tiefe in ihrem anspruch und mit
ihrer weisung erscheinen
ich erinnere an eine folge der jüngeren
politischen geschichte
in der hoffnung nicht als jahr
missverstanden zu werden und nicht zu
viele einseitige polemiken hervorzurufen
ich würde sagen dass das auftreten der
ökologischen bewegung in der deutschen
politik seit den 70er jahren zwar wohl
nicht fenster aufgerissen hat aber ein
schrei nach frischer luft gewesen ist
und bleibt den man nicht überhören war
nicht das handy kann weil man zu viel
irrationales darin findet
jungen menschen war bewusst geworden
dass irgendetwas in unserem umgang mit
der natur nicht stimmt
dass materie nicht nur material für
unser machen ist sondern dass die erde
selbst ihre würde in sich trägt und wir
ihrer weisung folgen müssen
es ist wohl klar dass ich hier nicht
propaganda für eine bestimmte politische
partei mache nichts liegt mir ferner als
das
[Applaus]
wenn in unserem umgang mit der
wirklichkeit etwas nicht stimmt dann
müssen wir alle ernstlich über das ganze
nachdenken und sind alle auf die frage
nach den grundlagen unserer kultur
überhaupt verwiesen
erlauben sie mir bitte dass ich noch
einen augenblick bei diesem punkt bleibe
die bedeutung der ökologie ist
inzwischen unbestritten
wir müssen auf die sprache der natur
hören und entsprechend antworten
ich möchte aber nachdrücklich einen
punkt ansprechen
der nach wie vor wie mir scheint
ausgeklammert wird es gibt auch eine
ökologie des menschen
auch der mensch hat eine natur die er
achten muss und die er nicht beliebig
manipulieren kann
der mensch ist nicht nur sich selbst
machende freiheit der mensch macht sich
nicht selbst erst geist und hilde
er ist geist und wille aber ist auch
natur und sein wille ist dann recht wenn
er auf die natur achtet zuhört und sich
annimmt dass der der er ist und er sich
nicht selbst gemacht hat gerade so und
nur so vollzieht sich wahre menschliche
freiheit gänge zurück zu den
grundbegriffen natur und vernunft von
denen wir ausgegangen waren
der große theoretiker des rechts
positivismus kelsen hat im alter von 84
jahren 1965 den dualismus von sein und
sollen aufgegeben es tröstet mich dass
mit 84 jahren offenbar doch noch etwas
vernünftiges denken kann
er hatte gesagt er hatte früher gesagt
dass norman nach dem willen kommen
können
die natur könnte folglich normen uhr
enthalten soll denn zu wenn ein wille
diese normen in sie hineingelegt hätte
dies wiederum sagte würde einen
schöpfergott voraussetzen dessen wille
in die natur mit eingegangen ist
über die wahrheit dieses glaubens zu
diskutieren ist völlig aussichtslos
bemerkte dazu wirklich möchte ich war
ist es wirklich sinnlos zu bedenken ob
die objektive vernunft die sich in der
natur zeigt nicht eine schöpferische
vernunft einen creator spiritus
voraussetzt
an dieser stelle müssen uns das
kulturelle erbe europas zu hilfe kommen
von der überzeugung eines schöpfergottes
her ist die idee der menschenrechte die
idee der gleichheit aller menschen vor
dem recht die erkenntnis der
unantastbarkeit der menschenwürde in
jedem einzelnen menschen und das wissen
um die verantwortung der menschen für
ihr handeln entwickelt
diese erkenntnisse der vernunft bilden
unser kulturelles gedächtnis ist
ignorieren oder als bloße vergangenheit
zu betrachten wäre eine amputation
unserer kultur insgesamt und würde sie
ihrer ganzheit berauben die kultur
europas ist aus der begegnung von
jerusalem athen und rom aus der
begegnung zwischen dem gottesglauben
israels der philosophischen vernunft der
griechen und dem rechtsdenken roms
entstanden
diese dreifache begegnung bildet die
innere identität europas
sie hat im bewusstsein der verantwortung
des menschen vor gott und in der
anerkenntnis der unantastbaren würde des
menschen eines jeden menschen maßstäbe
des rechts gesetzt die zu verteidigen
uns in unserer historischen stunde
aufgegeben ist dem jungen könig salomon
ist in der stunde seiner amtsübernahme
eine bitte freigestellt worden
wie wäre es wenn uns den gesetzgebern
von heute eine bitte freigestellt würde
was würden wir erbitten ich denke auch
heute können wir letztlich nichts
anderes wünschen als ein hörendes herz
die fähigkeit gut und böse zu
unterscheiden und so wahres recht zu
setzen der gerechtigkeit zu dienen und
dem frieden
ich danke ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit